what up what up this is joey ave and
make sure y'all check me out on the
bootleg cat podcast powder
blue
special guest my guy
dope boy troy troyer
is man the notorious ave yes sir man how
you been bro i'm blessed bro god is
going to paper [ __ ] i'm really blessed i
can't frank besides the fact that i
[ __ ] might have left on my jury in
the airport i i'm i'm really good i mean
it looks like you still have a lot of
jewelry on right now but no this i mean
it is but it ain't like i had like
everything i had my big bsv chain i had
my [ __ ] you left that on the plane i
left me when i got off the plane i went
to put my hoodie on and i took i took
the hoodie out and i had to take it out
to get to my hoodie oh hell no i'm just
like
i'm [ __ ] stressed how much money
potentially could you have lost if if no
one turned that in oh my gosh
bro i only want to begin to count but
one of the changes is
the big new bus down that i bought is
like 55
um
piece 25 another 40 65
100 something then i had some rings
then i had some bracelets oh my gosh
why travel why travel with all of that
though i got a [ __ ] video shooting oh
yeah i'm not just like i'm not like a
president i don't walk around wearing
jewelry all the time for no reason that
[ __ ] is like i don't give a [ __ ] about
jury but like i was gonna be having a
video i gotta go i'm hosting the party
just [ __ ] like that you know what i'm
saying
and it's [ __ ] this just sucks i'm like
well hopefully uh yeah hopefully i mean
whatever at the end of the day
it's just money long as you got your
health is whatever we get it back
tenfold you know what i'm saying so like
i'm i'm chipping about it now like [ __ ]
because it's happening right now
maybe yeah i'm literally just happening
god love me it literally just happened
literally just happened putting on a
[ __ ] hoodie because it was cold in
this [ __ ]
but i'm just like
[ __ ] oh no minutes you should be good
god love me should always seem to work
out for me so
that is true man um what have you been
up to i know you've been dropping music
but like just tell me what new album new
album god is great the paper's straight
new album out right now oh he's doing
very well you know what i'm saying it
was charted number one independent uh
number four for just hip hop overall
um
i didn't drop white christmas this year
but i'm i'm actually you know
i turned whenever i would do white
christmas what year it happened
jesus yeah crazy i remember the first
one you feel me yeah so
like we on now now
but um it just always felt like
it felt old to me when i would do
it promoting a project in in january
that's as christmas or february you feel
me so what i did now was i turned white
christmas into
it's gonna be called like the 2022
season and it's kind of like i went on
close when you're in it now when you're
in the nba you know okay
or whatever and you start talking about
your new season things you about to do
new year's resolutions just getting to
it like you know what i'm saying new
plans different [ __ ] like that but
that's all my people that's as
go-getters and hustlers like me and they
just gonna get to it you know this our
new season is what we doing right now
and that that'll take over as white
christmas it'll come out in december
this one is gonna come on in january but
it'll come out every december and just
you know i'll say a prayer bless the
people and we just go from there so the
2022 season is a new project
that's coming now i feel like you like
uh
still been putting out music still been
active but i feel like music hasn't
really been like
your focal point in life for a while
as far as like it's there because you're
putting it out but as far as like i feel
like you're not really interested in
being a part of the rap game anymore if
that makes sense um
oh i got a big single called the
weatherman out that's been getting good
traction you know i'm saying they
playing it all
on it on the east coast a lot on but
i've noticed like recently you're like
starting to dip your toe back into like
you know doing [ __ ] doing [ __ ] that like
you know
gonna rapper [ __ ] kel i really ain't i
really like music wasn't never like my
only focal point you know what i'm
saying because like i was
i've always been independent so i never
really liked
i never really liked trusting in it a
hundred percent you feel me so i always
was doing other businesses like any time
i got first rap money i started like
buying real real estate and [ __ ] like
that you got a lot of real estate yeah
just in case because life is full of
disappointments you know what i'm saying
but if you prepare for it then it's just
a disappointment could turn into a
lesson so i always never like been on it
on it like that but like you know it
just happened to be something i'm good
at and it was in this another hustle way
to get money if i could i could sell
bottles of water and make as much money
and get up whenever i went i wouldn't do
music i sell bottles of water so like i
definitely got a bunch of different
other business interests or whatever
you know by the grace god has shipped
and working out man so what is like your
biggest uh like piece of the pie as far
as like your your income is it the real
estate agent
i'm broke baby don't do me like that no
um
um as far as like
money
how much you tell me where are you
getting the most money in twenty i get
money from different different things i
got i got cargo vans i got um i got
merchandise the merchandise is crazy
goddess great paper straight the merch
game is nuts like do you sell a lot of
merch i mean yes a lot of merch make a
lot you've always been
been pretty big on the merch yeah even
before it was like a thing right but now
i got the hang of the hang of it before
it was like freestyling just figuring it
out a little bit but now it's like you
got to think if if say is like a couple
of people in this room if everybody buys
my album for ten dollars that'll only be
sixty bucks or whatever you said one
hoodie for sixty dollars oh i sell hats
for 250. you know what i'm saying that
people go people i just i just fill the
thousand dollar order people get 1500
whatever [ __ ] they just buy mad [ __ ] you
know what i'm saying that's even better
than sometimes somebody come to see you
and pay fifty dollars at a show
and then that [ __ ] lasts with them you
know what i mean so like the music is
a gateway to connect with your people
and then it's like they want to get more
and more so i sell [ __ ] aprons you
know what i mean for people cooking
during the holidays or every day
like i might sell candles and no kind of
[ __ ] i got all kind of [ __ ] i'm doing
you know i'm writing a movie i'm gonna
sell movies like okay
yeah so i just been staying busy man
yeah i mean what do you think like jerry
got me pissed bro i'm like yo this is
why you guys got an update
no we wait
that's a mission back to that airport
too
[ __ ] it man whatever
it's gonna work out y'all gotta go back
though we gotta go back right like you
gotta it's like when your car gets toe
you had your cartoon yeah you go
empty spot i had my car towed three
times last month bro that's okay why
because where i live
oh you didn't learn from see i used to
always get my [ __ ] towed i like needed
to have this little pass and like i'd be
yeah it was just you violated it was a
habit and you just did it yeah i was
just like man they had well they had
like swapped out the security the old
security was cool they didn't give a
[ __ ] then they hired a new company and
they just kept telling my i was so hot i
know i go you just get comfortable with
breaking the rules and it just keeps
going yeah i know how to [ __ ] go 800
hours later three three trips to an
impound that's nuts and my wife pissed
of course yeah because he just wasting
money that [ __ ] just flushed down the
toilet 100 what to get your car back
that's crazy yeah man um how are you
doing just in general though like i feel
like
you know like i said man if you you're
very active on social media yeah you
were doing the podcast i don't know if
you're still doing it i know you're not
doing it as often as you were doing it
that was like a pandemic thing you know
we all
we found time to do a lot of [ __ ] during
the pandemic and it was good it's so
like i'm like you know me you know i
like to [ __ ] with people who i [ __ ] with
and like i really [ __ ] with my
supporters and my friends like i really
if you take time to spend some money
with me some type of way when you don't
have to i really show genuine love so
instead of people asking me about what i
feel about this or that do a dm or
whatever i said let's just put it out
you can ask me questions i'll turn into
a podcast but like once outside open
back up then you know like the rest of
real life start happening and [ __ ] so
you know what i mean i got to take my
kids to school instead of on a [ __ ]
tablet right so like i got [ __ ] to do
you know what i mean
it was just a lot but i'm definitely
going to stop jump starting it again
because i've been in talks with the
company to have my [ __ ] like aired on on
on the um on a platform right you know
what i'm saying and well i don't have to
do like you see you got a production
team
i got that [ __ ] like i got that
road caster i got the vote it's me as me
recording it it's me editing it like
right that [ __ ] is a lot you feel me so
like now like you got the two cameras i
had a [ __ ] you got three cameras
i had two cameras and i'm like man
switch it back and forth was too much i
made it one camera
so like when you got to do a lot of that
[ __ ] it's just like
uh you i could be doing other [ __ ] with
my time to like because with me time is
really money right you feel me so we
spend i spend my time doing this i could
be taking it and doing other [ __ ] get
into a different bag
so that's why i was at that's where i'm
at with it right now
talk to me about like um
you know
there was like a point in time where
2014 2015 you're the hottest [ __ ] moving
in new york right uh
everyone in their mom's offering you
record deals
was i know that there was a lot of money
on the table
it wasn't okay i'm gonna let you guys i
just mean like
i remember like you know talking to
whole vain back then and be like man
everyone's trying to sign us right now
but we need this
to even like think about doing it they
were trying to stegoshin to sign us on
some
on some homeboy [ __ ] like trying to sign
us for free my grandmother so i thought
that might have happened like you know
it didn't that didn't
it was like i i told tibby i want two
million dollars you know what i'm saying
he said which one i want two million
dollars and he was trying to
give me like less and then saying yo
let's go to the label and get i'm like
and you you got it just give it to me
that's what i would do if i want an
artist i'm just giving the bread so like
i always believe in myself and i never
want to be tied down and restrained
saying you know like the worst
fear or like just growing up seeing
people on music getting signed and
getting shelf and you just boxed in so i
would never like i always would bet on
myself like man unless it's something
crazy like that i don't like two million
dollars you feel me like i didn't had 2
million dollars at the time i
i had hundreds of thousands of dollars
so you can't offer me hundreds of
thousands because i already got it you
know what i'm saying so unless somebody
make you like the mob i'm gonna make you
a deal you can't refuse
i was like yo two million dollars
because i know i never go broke again if
you give me that mm-hmm you could turn
two to ten you felt exactly that's why
like i knew yo if i got that freshman
cover i was gonna make a million dollars
and i'll take it to the top but i know
if you get two million dollars in life
and you're hustling you'll never go
broke again
but you know he didn't uh whatever
reason that that didn't happen like i
was just i wasn't never signing for no
[ __ ] that i didn't that i had already it
made no sense because i knew i would
work i knew i would make myself right
get get my own opportunities and you
know like even like all i wanted out of
rap was
i wanted a building i wanted a ferrari
and i wanted a a gold a gold record
and i [ __ ] got all three of those
yeah yeah that's crazy that's all i ever
wanted out of out of music the gold
record came like at like i wanted it
after but i got she belonged to the game
right she belongs to the game he's on
his way to platinum that's crazy
straight up like really independent you
know what i'm saying what was like the
situation that you were closest to like
signing with in that during that time
everyone was everyone was trying to sign
you bro like everybody they would if you
i feel like if you trying to sound
somebody i feel like if you cap channels
if you really jump that's when i if you
really try to sound somebody just give
them what they want man you feel me so
like
i want to say it wasn't no situation
i like to if
like with all artists just know who you
getting in bed with you know what i'm
saying like i'm saying with anybody just
don't be so quick to billy yo yeah
i want to sign i want to just
nah just make sure that you know you're
going to get everything that you want or
it's not worth it if you a real hustler
and like if you i this is what i want to
say i understand when people talk a
bunch of get money [ __ ] name music you
know what i'm saying and then they turn
around and they sign to somebody and
then they rely on that person to give
them everything to come up
or you know what i'm saying you know
that happens a lot you because then it's
like you're not really a hustler or
everything you talking about was capped
or if you sign up somebody and then you
don't and then in turn you sign for like
you sell for peanuts but it's if you
gonna sign for peanuts make sure you
getting a bunch of [ __ ] on the back end
yeah you gotta have a actually like good
structure deal because you know you're
gonna have to whatever you get something
for you're gonna pay you're gonna have
to pay that money back yeah i knew i was
gonna make whatever money back because
all my projects is always in the black
no matter what it co i got my in-house
production i produce i write i record do
all my [ __ ] so well there's not a lot
there's not a lot of
overhead it'd cost somebody else
[ __ ] 250 000 to make an album
and it cost me
10 000 and it's just gonna be just as
fire only thing that's gonna suffer is
the marketing dollars and not for the
lack of money just the lack of resources
not having the right people you know
because [ __ ] come here to
promote their projects and [ __ ] in their
albums you know what i'm saying i'm on
here because you know you're my man
right right you know i got i got a
little little bit of clout but just
imagine all the other people who don't
have that they got just as good music
right but they don't have the access to
get to a bootleg cave or to go wherever
you want to go to
so you know i just thank god i got good
relationships and uh and i'm i'm not
scared of hard work uh you just put a
song on a soldier boy oh yeah draco's in
glass that's [ __ ] extremely random
in a million years i never thought i
would be like yo yeah troy having
soldier but i would love it
say that man name right the drago nah
that he's the homie like he's come on
the show a lot like i [ __ ] with him i
feel like his management like
yeah that's my god no it's cool it's
cool but like what well how did that
happen that's super always f i always
[ __ ] with soji always being loved like
in passing or whatever whatever like i
[ __ ] with
i [ __ ] with a lot of people let me not
say a lot of people i'll [ __ ] with
people that i genuinely [ __ ] with you
know what i'm saying like not offer so
like if i [ __ ] with the artist i'm not
like i [ __ ] with gates you know what i'm
saying we don't got a song but if we pop
up with a song i'll probably get gates
from some this year but yo that was
random but i've been [ __ ] with gates
for years yeah that would make more
sense to me though
see with this this i do i don't
like i'm not a dick rider so i don't
just do records with somebody because
they got a buzz hill i want to get their
fans saying no i want that [ __ ] to feel
good sonically like even when i dropped
my project made you without a deal
i had a great project you filmed thank
you i had all the people on it that i
grew up listening to that i admired and
i put them perfectly where they needed
to sound in pocket i had fat joke
perfectly in pocket i had recall prodigy
and nori perfectly in pocket i didn't
say well at that time of course there's
other rappers there's hotter than them
that i could do collabs and get their
fans but it never been about that i've
never been to cloud chase never been a
dick rider i want to make the best music
possible and i know how to put
[ __ ] on beats that they gonna
sound in the pocket so this beat right
here
this [ __ ] had that feeling you know when
soldier told i said yo i need you to
talk that go crazy on that [ __ ] i don't
need you
make it clap i need you to go crazy do
that yelling in the [ __ ] camera [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying it's a fact
draco [ __ ] yeah the big draco i need you
to do the big draco and he did the big
draco in his fire i got another jelly
coming out with um
with trap boy freddy and he's dope you
know what i'm saying people will say
that's reno but i'll [ __ ] with him we we
got we got dog business and coming you
know what i'm saying bsb bullies on the
way so you're breeding dogs yeah that's
a fact
so um who's okay this might be a random
super paws question
but when you have a dog then i'm gonna
start breeding right well i'm gonna
start studying them out who is jerking
off your dog don't juggle your dog you
gotta take it to the uh take it to the
um so my boy does it himself and he
makes like 300 grand a year jerk and
he's be jerking his dog off and i'm like
bro i'm not touching no dicks for no
amount of money doug
no dicks in life like i mean it's a dog
even like even like if i got to change
my kids diaper it's a lot of baby wipes
i'm never fizzing my my fingers ain't
touching anything i just what i'm
curious because i just got a frenchie
that's like a puppy man i'm like oh am i
gonna have to jerk this dog no you can
take it to the vet and then you the vet
will drink the dog exactly unless and
they'll leave you you get this to get
the [ __ ] in there the specimen and you'd
be out but like you got to think how
much is it worth for you is it you this
is what i look at if if a [ __ ]
try to yo hey i'm gonna save myself for
150 dollars and just yeah it's only if
it's only 150 bucks i'm paying the 150.
but then it's like i'll pay the 150 to
someone i know to jerk the dog off just
oh you gotta show them
yeah and then i could i could hold it
over their head forever like bro you
jerked off late
yeah because they're not a certified
jerk offer so you gotta charge them less
you know what i mean
but yeah i i think um yeah i'm not
jugging off no dogs at all
uh leader at the joe buttons man oh my
goodness did you see uh recently i mean
he was on his podcast a couple weeks ago
and he said that he would he would fight
you for free
or some [ __ ] maybe no no no no he oh
he's cat he's catching some [ __ ] like
that i'm by the way i might be totally
i've listened to the podcast
and he and he had said like um that
there's no like
real beef between you guys but if he had
to do like a celebrity fight
yeah
who whatever you gotta do with celebrity
fight what like you guys each getting
500k you're doing the fight yeah that's
the fact i
i don't
[ __ ] beat people up for less funny
enough for nothing yeah what's up like
where where was the uh i mean you guys
have kind of had like a nice snow
a little riff for a while now you juggy
joe like amazed whatever i don't get
but you know i don't got no b for nobody
in the new year 2020 that's good yeah
that's good especially like in the
podcast space because
i like
i don't want to say i i don't use the
term respect loosely but like
if every like people that are doing [ __ ]
like how you doing this podcast
academics like junkie joe like a bunch
of people doing these [ __ ] i i say it
endearingly like [ __ ] you was it junkie
but it's okay a lot of junkies it's all
right long as you get better but anyway
you know like [ __ ] are doing
some [ __ ] that i so this is dope let me
child let me aspire to do this so i give
credit where credit is due
um all and and [ __ ] this man other
people doing [ __ ] yeah it's it's a lot
of dope pocket i feel like i'm
forgetting somebody man
there's no podcast
drink champs millions of dollars
[ __ ] yeah so
yeah so like i feel like you can't
really
when i when i say something it's gonna
be based on facts i'm not just gonna go
and be like trying to diss cause i feel
like you can't
but that again that's a handicap cause
people don't do that people people look
people look up and talk down
you can't [ __ ] do that right you know
what i mean that's coney you feel me and
that that means that if somebody's doing
something that you if like me i got mad
buildings in real estate man
multi-family homes right and if somebody
talking [ __ ] about me and they don't
they live in an apartment like oh yeah
real estate or whatever like you can't
do that though because you're trying to
get into what i get into
now if you say something factual about
me that got nothing to do with that then
cool but you still got to have a certain
level of uh
i don't want to say respect but
like a certain level because you trying
to get into that space as them
or whatever
um
not saying i give a [ __ ] about podcasts
i'm just saying it's just another it's
just another move another outlet for me
to talk to my people right and of course
spread your own news because if you
don't tell yourself
yeah exactly you have your own
narratives you know what i'm saying um
help me man
what you know i felt like you were in a
position where everyone was embracing
you
everyone was kind of
[ __ ] with troy ave i feel like
then there was like a switch that
happened and it felt like
it just kind of felt like a lot of
people kind of deserted you or at least
you're like like did you feel that way
like like
where you weren't get getting embraced
as much after something happened uh you
know i mean i can't never stop felt
deserted because i always been on my own
i always been like independent 100 i
just mean in terms of like on some
industry [ __ ] man i use i ain't never
i don't want to say deserted or anything
kev i just want to say like
it's like
when
it's like everybody petting the lion
until the lions show his teeth and show
his real teeth and it's like
[ __ ] it's [ __ ] on some other
[ __ ] and they could get on some other
[ __ ]
at any time right and you know how this
[ __ ] goes in his in his music [ __ ] is
like
his entertainment his wwf
everybody is a [ __ ] wrestler
but
when the guy really slams you on your
neck and you get injured then it's like
oh [ __ ] whoa whoa we wrestling for fake
we're not wrestling for her
so
that happens a lot where it's just like
it just if if you do some extremely [ __ ]
that's so-called gangster or real and or
they'll turn that into saying
is
idiotic and it's it's uh
it's [ __ ] um
what you call what's what's the word
it's it's uh hazardous and [ __ ] like
that and then people want to get away
from that you feel me because it's like
you don't know what but in certain
instances if you're
leveled up and clouded up more like
assigned to a major label and [ __ ] like
that they got to deal with you like
people didn't [ __ ] with 50 cent
they had for you because he was with
dreaming
it was too late it was the hottest
rapper in the world so like you got it
it was too late it was like damn we
can't you're going to [ __ ] with him and
look
he could have [ __ ] shootouts and
getting his [ __ ] and then but we can't
not [ __ ] with him because it's he going
to be at all award shows he's with jimmy
ivy and it's too late i was just with me
i felt like you also like you were doing
some small things that made people root
against you
oh there would be like you know like
maybe it'd be like the kendrick lamar is
a weirdo rapper line when like can't
everyone's [ __ ] with kendrick yes
this is just all of them okay let's just
address that that's just made one by one
that was on new york city i was in new
york city the album now that's what i'm
trying to say
you do
when you do some real [ __ ] it's like
whoa whoa whoa that's too real i didn't
know
i came in the game like thinking
like i put it to wwe wrestling i always
seen the wrestlers growing up i thought
they was real
[ __ ] they doing this okay when somebody
say something about you when snoop say
he crushed the buildings nori and uh cnn
came at him a couple other people
whatever came like turn [ __ ] up yeah
that's how you post you posted react and
defend that's what i thought it was you
know i'm saying so when
when [ __ ] uh kendrick lamar said the
[ __ ] about new york and everybody had
their paintings and a bunch of [ __ ] i'm
like all right all you
[ __ ] making whole songs is
that's why is it that my win
my [ __ ] one bar stuck more than wait
you said was that before the control
freestyle no it was after after why
would i say that i don't know yeah that
made no sense so like i'm only
everything like people with those stones
and they hide their hands they only see
the reaction because my reaction is so
aggressive and
savage but there's no rules to a
reaction like i say if somebody slap you
and you mind in your business they slap
you and you get up and you [ __ ]
bludgeon them or beat them with a bat
they should have never slapped you
so
everybody making whole diss records
about
kendrick lamar because he said to new
york right i think jay-z even did a
verse and then just never put it out
right like mad people had records and it
was just nothing but there's one line
by little old independent choice i just
think i just think it's so hard yeah
yeah and i didn't say nothing crazy how
to capture you didn't say anything super
disrespectfully i just i said he's a
weirdo rapper which which was like but
now [ __ ] want to use widow
rappers as a term now like it was a
little rapper compared to the [ __ ] you
were doing
not me doing just right
i see this is why i don't like i don't
like when media people
everybody try to act like
try to just have alternative facts
if
from the look you got a bunch of [ __ ]
plaques on here right from these people
we grew up looking at the clips these
same [ __ ] people packing big
if they were like
because you got me talking about it see
how when kendrick lamar came out on
stage and he had the white [ __ ] on
mm-hmm you know what i'm saying yeah
yeah that was recently yeah right like
i mean but he's just little roots and
jizzy on the wall and kanye up there
yeah you know kanye is fire the root
state
the roots you know what they all mean
like there's nothing wrong with having
there's nothing wrong with people having
titles i mean and also that if that was
if that was like a a retort for the
control freestyle it makes sense that's
all it was i mean that's all it was it
was like you would jump in the city yeah
which you gonna be a [ __ ] and i
represent every single one of my songs
since day one from my mixtape it always
been new york i even had my singles yo
new york while everybody else was trying
to dick right and sound like no for sure
you definitely like all these first
bricks in the backpack [ __ ] like well i
don't know how many songs i got about
brooklyn how many songs i got about new
york and i'm spending my own money to
promote this when i know it'll keep me
local but by me keep pushing and pushing
i'm repping i'm loyal to where i'm from
right and everybody should be like that
i love when i love when i come where i
hear yg first album and it [ __ ] sound
like ellen yeah you feel me when you
hear
new york city albums sound like new york
you know what i'm saying i want to hear
[ __ ] young thugs sounding like
atlanta or or young jeezy [ __ ] you know
what i mean like shit's got to sound
like where it's from
there's nothing wrong with collabing
when big got with bone thug that was the
perfect collaboration sure that's where
he started filming he kept his new york
voice and he did their family he did
their flow yeah did it better than them
i mean i don't know i i'm bringing
you're working with steve lobel now so
oh my god
oh man
but yeah yeah so that that was one thing
so that was one thing yo stop in the
interview got to tell you about our good
folks at odd socks man listen go to odd
socks official dot com use the promo
code 20 off save 20 off some of the
craziest socks you know they got the
ninja turtle joints
uh shout out to kool-aid you know what
i'm saying shout out to spongebob plus
they got the odd socks basics
these are my boys right here i love
these right here you get the plain black
the plain white very comfortable most
comfortable socks in the world to be
honest you know what i'm saying plus
underwear y'all cheez-it draws
come on what are we doing go to
oddssoxofficial.com use the promo code
bootleg and save 20
off the most comfortable underwear in
the world [ __ ] all that other [ __ ]
you'll be wearing on your ass throw all
the methicas in the trash all that psd
[ __ ] all that [ __ ] is all
listen man put the mod socks on your ass
cheeks and thank me later
no no no the other thing
do you regret the capital steez thing
with joey
don't zoom in on my face when i'm
smiling
um see you getting raw emotions out of
me i'm just asking i'm just asking
at that time i mean i mean i know you
were on your troy have [ __ ] like in
retrospect do you regret that at all oh
he's on i'm just me man i mean like
listen man this how i feel
what can can you uh bring the people up
to speed with what i what i said and why
i said it because i want to make sure
because just like well you didn't know
that that was in response to the control
freestyle i want to make sure that this
so the joey thing i felt like
like what the fact is like well listen i
don't know why you said it i know that
at the time you don't know why i know
that you guys are going back and forth
to who was selling more records
independently
right that was kind of the wasn't back
and forth i wasn't concerned with who
was selling more like his independence
out of new york uh
that wasn't me i wasn't back and forth
you had brought up
the fact that
his one of one of the guys in pro era
capital steez had killed himself and
said some un um
probably some not nice things about
about that situation
this isn't look you got the clips on
your wall you got 50 center in your wall
you don't have the locks here didn't
they talk about 50s mother they died
but what was it what what let me ask you
guys then pushing cause it's okay this
has been like five or six years don't do
that look i don't know because
what i'm trying to do is know what i'm
trying to do is ask you like what like
like for people who don't know and even
refresh my memory what was the origin of
the issue with joey where that that
statement before before before i forget
i want to set the premise i want because
it's very important in the environment
the rap that that i grew up listening to
as a kid is
clips this is pusha t he's one of the
greatest he
didn't he go crazy on android man
producer
cerebral palsy or something okay
50 cent he was going
nuts on everybody and they went nuts on
him it is it is what it is
and this is tupac hit him up and like
you got these people on your wall right
no i do and the [ __ ] that they said was
the [ __ ] they said was but i think that
their issues with the
with the other side of the the
exchange were probably uh at least a lot
more stronger than what your at least
what your issues might have been with
joey
no well well the issue started with joey
was i was minding my business just doing
my thing independent i was only just
independent and i always said bsb rack
is the number one independent label out
of new york
you know what i'm saying and then um
i don't know i think he might have said
something about it or maybe not i don't
remember but i know something like his
um
a friend of his came on a record and he
was like yeah
and such and such so more records in
choi
now again i dropped my i dropped my
project major without a deal
and you know they try to
like you seem like people always coming
for me you know i mean because it's like
a bunch of fake
people and when they see the rail they
don't want to really shine because then
you make them look funny if you bring
real diamonds around [ __ ] with
fake [ __ ] then they start looking funny
so well let's get them out of here so
they said oh troy ave took a l i only
sold a couple thousand records or
whatever right that wasn't really true
i dropped my i dropped my album on a
friday when everybody else was dropping
these [ __ ] on a tuesday yeah we talking
about pure record souls for that week i
actually sold 14 000 right for people
who don't know this was before it got
switched to fridays this before people
are going to be in the comments like man
[ __ ] comes out for so back back then it
was tuesday's musical drop
so when you drop on a friday you're not
driving you're not getting it full
you're not getting a full week and then
i didn't care about that i'm independent
i'm like man i'm gonna drop all the
money i'm gonna keep saying music
exactly
so i drop it
and then i sell a couple thousand
records but mind you it's a short week
and then remember i'm independent
i sold a couple thousand that's all free
money too right i'm making more of my
couple thousand records so it ended up
selling fourteen thousand like later on
with the week
i make a hundred and forty thousand that
that whole album only cost me probably
ten thousand to make and this is pretty
priest before streaming yeah this is
none of this [ __ ] straight it's straight
buying straight
yeah that's a fact
and now i'm getting 90 percent of that
95 percent like it's a difference was it
still was this through empire
you know yeah yeah yeah [ __ ] with empire
so um this this early like empire days
you know yeah for sure after my lawyer
vinnie kumar he put that play together
and it made and it made sense and he's
that man he's a goat so um
so
now when i'm doing that
like
you can't ever tell me
you can't ever tell me i look at it like
you got people that's playing on ringer
teams and if your team is fully loaded
and you got everybody on the team and
and [ __ ] you got lebron and you got
d wade and [ __ ] like that and then you
come on and you score
20 points
that's not
that 20 points ain't more than
the guy who has
who's carrying that's 20 points ain't
more than a.r taking the philadelphia
uh to the championship with the lakers
right it's not more right it's not more
than you feel me
it's not more than but they'll try to
make it and when i say loaded teams
marking in
um
big money behind behind [ __ ] um
um promotions um everything just you
know real public is like everything so
if
if they spending 250 000 to push this
[ __ ]
and then you
maybe sell a little bit more than me
if i'm only spending ten thousand
dollars
this is a bigger win
because then you could only do that one
time a year i could do this [ __ ] three
four times a year
but
then try to act like what i did was a l
when it's not a l so i ain't never gonna
be quiet
like where i'm from you you don't just
let somebody say something about you and
then you you not say nothing and you
just fall back and like that sucker [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying right
so
uh somebody that would never uh that
would never
just i never said nothing about nobody
on a record or anything that i would not
definitely say in their face when i see
them and that's what i didn't like about
the music and internet [ __ ] people will
say things about you just randomly they
got access to say some [ __ ] that they
wouldn't say and growing up growing up
in my in motherhood like you got to see
about that person right there and have
that energy when you say that you that's
called hating right or you're just a
sucker and so somebody artist just came
and took a shot and said and such and
such so more records in troy oh i think
he said it um joey said it such and such
show more records in troy one of his
artists
i'm like why the [ __ ] would you say that
like that didn't make you why you said
that to me now mind you it wasn't no it
wasn't that big of a deal
because like it wasn't like a bunch of
people was like oh whatever whatever but
i just caught window there i'm like
why the [ __ ] would you say that to me
knowing that like like if i if i saw you
it would it would be a problem
why are you starting with me why are you
playing with me like that like i don't
it makes you more upset when somebody
play with you that would never
if you not there like that's not real
[ __ ] a real a real person would never go
dis somebody and then know when they
when they see them they wouldn't say
that it wouldn't i don't i don't believe
in that pop [ __ ] and apologize
i suck at [ __ ] right you don't pop [ __ ]
and then when you see you playing the
yola [ __ ] and talk it out yo it's so
good that [ __ ] should have never
happened why did it happen mm-hmm and
then you tell me why it happened why
would someone i'm sure i've never took a
shot at nobody out of nowhere or no
records for what for clout just for what
because when you disrespect then you
open the door to be down with all the
disrespect that comes with it
so do you feel like they was down for
all the disrespect that comes with it or
was they just i mean how do you feel i
mean i think that be honest
let me tell you something this is what
happened
so that happened
i remember that line you're saying now
now i remember the joey line you're
talking about which happened first also
not at not even in the same ballpark of
disrespect as what you came and retorted
with i didn't know we played ballparks
at districts but listen but listen but
but but i know but what i want to get to
is like because for a long time
so like i'll give you an example once
that happened
you had a record at that time that was
getting pushed to radio i don't remember
which song it was
i don't remember either but i don't
remember it yeah
it might have been but it
i don't know what it was but you had a
record that was getting insulted in the
place yeah it was offended i think i was
like
but i'm like
my boy in minneapolis who's playing your
record on the radio right
the station called uh go 95 96 3.
um
and he calls me and he's like yo we're
like supporting troy
and like yo he's like disrespecting
people who like
have families that have gone through
suicide [ __ ] like what
how how how are they taking it that
person and the crazy [ __ ] is i really
[ __ ] with him whenever i would go out
there we would tap in like i really
[ __ ] with him so this is that's the
prime minister he's calling me and i'm
like
yo man i could just talk to hoevane
you know how but but you know i think i
talked to you right from a record of
somebody starting something with me and
then i'd respond i think it was just
that
i spoke to you too yeah but how does
that affect other people in positions of
doing their job like it's not a personal
thing if you got a good record you got a
good record throw it on and [ __ ] with it
i don't know what is this record i don't
disagree with you it's not that specific
instance
it's not even like i'm saying play this
record this record is just a diss record
in response to what they said to me and
it went crazy but how how in the [ __ ]
world is that okay for somebody's
personal feelings
about what two other men have a problem
with to affect
you pushing a [ __ ] or you playing just
don't push you just play it regularly
it's a good record right right everybody
everybody love director i remember which
i forget which record it was i don't
know you had
during that era you had a few so oh and
maybe she would launch the game maybe
doo doo doo it might have been
or she belongs to the game i feel like i
don't know but
whatever but no but so let me ask you
this do you feel like did you do you
feel like that that specific line
[Music]
like you like i went too far no no i i
well you obviously don't feel like you
went too far but do you feel like yeah
i didn't say that do you feel like it
uh affected you and your career at all
negatively
um because because that one anecdotal
situation we just talked about about a
single radio station in minnesota that's
nice but there's other no there's other
people but that's what i felt like
because i feel like a lot of people were
like oh triad we're off that
[ __ ] like he's he took it too
far like
because they they just they just wait
they
they was never really
[ __ ] with me because i
i stand for everything that they don't i
stand for independence i stand for being
confident they're called my confidence
cocky they'll call my independent cells
mediocre when in reality my independence
sales are superior to yours because i
made more money
and um
like i feel like that was just a way for
people to come out and have something to
say like how any problem with between
two men it's more just look at chicago
they talk about smoking dead ops
listen who i do not disagree right now
especially like in jacksonville [ __ ] is
funny you fell me to who i smoked but it
but it been
music been disrespectful
i think people just looked at it as like
joey's like this kid was just making
dope young rap music you're from new
york and maybe as opposed to like you
guys having an issue and like it being
like a thing like
you know and at the time you guys were
definitely
you know
your your guys's rises were parallel to
each other not not related to each other
it wasn't really parallel he was way uh
he was way ahead of me already i just
mean in terms of like you guys are both
up and coming in new york city your
energy was a lot different obviously but
so joey still was making like joke like
joey badass could have been on new york
city the album and that would have made
sense and it would have sounded good
right
no he couldn't have been on new york
city album not that album i'm not i'm
just meaning in terms of like not i'm
not sure i was disappointed those type
of beats you know what i'm saying like
[ __ ] no hell no absolutely not how
where you know who's on new york city
album tell me if you you can't tell me
one person that no let alone put on you
can't tell me one person that i could
take off to play morning no i'm not
talking i cannot say that i'm not saying
that he could fit where he cannot you
could pull all the stones that there's
no way that music is different they was
making backpack rap music i think he was
making traditional new york nineties
boombap [ __ ] traditional new york 90s i
don't make i don't make 90s yeah i'm not
but i'm not saying you but i'm i'm
making [ __ ] incarcerated skull faces
i'm making capital punishment i'm making
i think i'm making dumb and i don't
think joey
i don't think joey [ __ ] was far from
that wheelhouse how both brothers are
two different types of hip-hop
i'm telling i'm i grew up in that space
those are two i guess
this is listen
has most def and jay-z
um tell us
and hold on to the jc album no but talib
and jay has done [ __ ] uh well i never
heard tyler carley on a jay-z album
never not on a jc album but they've
they've been on on a record together
they get by remix
that's come on give me a jab you know
hip-hop kev don't do that come on catch
what you mean jay was on to the quality
[ __ ] so most def make dope ass music
right
so even tyler quality be flowing
but them two type of albums are
different they they it doesn't go so you
can't say he could have been on new york
city the album no or major idea no
[ __ ] way it it's not that how about
this joey has records with all the guys
that are on new york city of the album
i'm pretty sure when no i i i'll call
cap
over honey some thousands of jewelry i'm
gonna find out who's on the outside but
i gotta dance
[Music]
rayquan
um
pusha t
um
no not push t jdk is fabulous oh man p i
i bet you anything there's no there's
never no cap with joey ass i don't i
don't just do to assume you know how
people just throw out a fact
i guess the point i'm trying to say is i
feel like you like divided y'all so much
like and i think some people made it ma
had maybe thought it was unnecessary
what was that there's no rules to a
reaction that's fair if if somebody
comes and slaps you right now in your
face what would you do kev somebody just
randomly walks in and i react
like what would your reaction be just
randomly but violence like like what
kind of violence i don't know uh a punch
uh
a punch is more severe than a slap right
this is true
but do you not think that some of the
things you were saying in the interviews
were kind of like
like he could have loosely taken them as
like
yo was he talking about us
i was never wit and what in it never
know when you were talking about like
like being the biggest like like rapper
out of new york no i said i'm the number
one independent rapper out of new york i
still am to this day
but how i'm only speaking facts there's
nothing wrong with speaking your facts i
don't listen i'm i'm just trying i'm
independent when you see my [ __ ] it's a
bsb records
did you feel like some of the industry
turned their back on you when that
happened i feel like different things
like that happen like you said um
the guy in minneapolis
[ __ ] like that started happening right
and even people that was like
would call me and they'd be like no what
you're saying is right but you know you
can't say that like that in public why
the [ __ ] can i this is rap y'all didn't
tell me the rules before i got into this
[ __ ] i'm watching i'm thinking
i'm thinking these people really [ __ ]
doing power drives and really doing
clotheslines i'm thinking this is what
really happens right oh it's fake it's
not real but i didn't know that i didn't
find it out until i do some real [ __ ]
then it's like whoa what's going on and
then like you got to think at the end of
the day anybody that got a problem with
what i said took my suicide if you go
against me you got something wrong what
i got to say
then take it up with god you got
something to say with the whole bible
that's my only back and that's what i'm
standing on i'm standing on that so i
want the same people that got some
uh against what i got to say make sure
you say i don't [ __ ] with god i don't
[ __ ] with no religion that speaks
against that
anything
that you can't be a [ __ ] hypocrite
i'm i don't i don't deal with the
hypocrisy it's corny that's a fact so
what you what you did was a christian
move no
i'm not i'm not
he said man i'm not gonna say i'm not
gonna say i'm a christian i practice
realism because i don't believe in
dividing i don't believe in dividing
like they try to divide and conquer us
people say
as a fact
everything i don't believe you never i
don't have no hate in me at all i don't
have no [ __ ] racism i don't hate on
somebody for being [ __ ] gay i don't
hate on somebody for getting money i
don't hate them smite because they want
gender none of that [ __ ] so if you if
what they try to do is is like separate
us in different little [ __ ] where if
this person is saying allah this person
is saying the messiah and i'm saying god
it's a jewish uh a muslim and uh
christian enemies you all saying the
same thing you all believe in god that's
the common denominator [ __ ] everything
else that has to go below so i practice
realism you know the semantics of
religion has been pretty much the cause
of most wars and it's the semantics it's
the same thing and dividing conquer like
there's nothing wrong with being in
putting groups but at the end of the day
if you all believe in one thing then
let's focus on that so like
like focus on what we all have in common
exact exact and that's oh that's all i
push i never yo anytime i ever said
anything i'm not thinking about nobody
else when i say i'm the number one
independent labeling uh in new york i am
i started this from the ground up i
really sold fifty five thousand records
out of my chunk oh no
for sure so i'm the number one
independent i'm really doing doing the
most repping for the city these other
people
joey whoever they are head starts with
me they wasn't like rep [ __ ]
first time i met yg
he said this [ __ ] from new york
this is what i'm talking about right
there because i look and i sound like it
i'm not you're not going to meet
um
i don't i'll [ __ ] with tyler crowley but
you're never going to meet uh most death
back in the day but yeah this is what
new york is like and most deaf is dope
as [ __ ] right
you're not going to say that you're
going to say that about biggie you're
going to say that about jay-z i think
yeah i think on a commercial level
you're right yes
just period
how commercial just period in general
that's the energy that's what that's
what it's about
my my energy wasn't a
retro energy finger snapping [ __ ] like i
said i definitely think you had the um
like the closest
you know because i think after 50
there was a lot of people who try to be
the the new the new 50 or the new that
that kind of like that feel that
position i guess i would say and i feel
like at that time you're the closest
person that got to that and i think
that's why at that time
you know got behind like 50 you know put
his arm around you for a second right
first 50 he was hating and then he came
he came around after that what's your
relationship with 50 now he good i mean
if i see him i see him it's so good like
that's that's me i'll never
like 50 inspired me like i was saying
about the junkie joe [ __ ] you know what
i'm saying so i never had nothing bad to
say about them because if it wasn't no
50 it wouldn't be me but i'm not trying
to sound like him and i'm doing my own
thing you feel me and
and so like back to i want to stay on
this because we gotta get rid of some of
these
uh alternative facts just like we did
with the kendrick [ __ ] nobody knew that
i uh said that [ __ ] about kendrick
because he said this and it was a fact i
just pointed out it was a fact i didn't
lie when i said this [ __ ] everybody oh
when he did this song with miguel and i
don't know what he was wearing or brazie
had everybody like yo choi was right i
mean to call someone the weirdo though
is subjective
a weirdo to you yes
that's the fact
which is fine you spoke your truth it's
it's not
would you say the clips
are the clips talking of cocaine rap
yeah that's that's the definition of
coke rap
exactly like we
you might have called him a weirdo
rapper at that time
no well not not because where i'm from
you see a lot of brothers that are way
coofies and [ __ ] like that even in jail
they're not widows i would never call
numbers i i just know that kendrick
isn't a weirdo but it's every we could
put every artist into who who they are
snoop dogg maybe you're right your
definition of weirdo kendrick is a
weirdo i don't think he's a weirdo
because i know kendrick and i know he's
just i'm i'm i understand what you were
saying i don't know kenji you were
applied
you replied to the free style
establishment i'm talking about stylish
yeah we've established that
right so
just see when you know somebody more
person whatever but back to the to the
to the joey bad [ __ ] when you seen them
like i said what i said
i'm break i'm lyrical with it i'm
breaking them down and since they said a
partner of his he brought other people
into it it wasn't just him going hr he
brought up somebody from his group sell
more records in troy okay so now it's
open season or
anybody from your group here or going
you feel me that's what happened they
they opened pandora's box and then
chopping whoa whoa you went too far
don't play with me did anyone around you
hear that and try to convince you to
take it out
um
they
the video they was like yo come on the
video was nuts because i did the video
on the roof yeah yeah but i mean like i
said look all these [ __ ] you
got on your wall you got them on your
wall tupac hit him up come on take if
you feel away about it if you're not
standing on how troy have went about his
business then you need to take tupac off
your wall or else you're being if that
was a more serious situation what are
you talking about serious to who
seriousness is objective
seriously if somebody slaps you in your
face you don't have to respond to them
with a punch you i've seen people get
slapped like all the cops oh no i've
seen people get cyber damn what's wrong
with this guy he's crazy
yeah i mean
so everything you say i'm only speaking
with facts listen nobody can tell nobody
can tell anyone how to react to
something right so you have been that
was more serious than if i'm this this i
just
i'm just telling you the perception of
i'm not telling you
you you like my opinions because i'm on
the bootleg podcast i don't know man i
think
i'm not on the perception i think at the
time
i definitely think at the time
it was when i'm here real [ __ ] i didn't
come here run out yo kevin i got to go
running and go get my [ __ ] i'm really no
we're here we're here no i i feel like
um
at that time
to me it felt unnecessary it felt over
the top for at the moment like
new york we always hear about how
atlanta moves together
you know why can't new york and la move
together like atlanta does and at that
time
it felt like you were you would like
carved out troy have island
and you were just standing on your
island in new york when i said that you
mean yeah and just in general i just
feel like you i feel like you were i
mean i knew you at the you know i know
you so like i was very close to your
situation right um
and so i would like you know i'd be like
yeah well [ __ ] it seems like a lot of
people are rooting against you
as opposed to rooting for you and i
think that that was because of some of
the things you would say some of and
that's just you being you just being
it's just me being a real person i am on
troye violin because i i'm self-made and
self-paid nobody put me on and brought
me up i had 100 percent you did it from
the ground up
i mean i call it dj's like i used to
call you everybody
very much tattooed
but with these two situations that you
bringing up
who started them they were all reactions
i didn't and that's important that's
important no one can tell any individual
how to react to something but i'm asking
do you do you agree it was all that did
i mean how did we bash it was it was it
a reaction who i i agree that you
reacted you went through the first shot
i mean based on
the recollection
yeah yeah bro listen it's been so long
yeah but so yeah absolutely so yeah so i
do remember that line that joey dropped
so that's him throwing a shot at me and
so you you're that was your reaction to
someone who threw a shot at you first
because you had never thrown a shot at
him prior to that correct oh directly no
i don't throw i don't be going around
throwing shots i be focused on me i'm
not worried about what another man doing
i'm focused on so we've established that
you reacted to joey and you reacted to
the control freestyle and the kendrick
thing i just think people were like what
the [ __ ] but i think people it wasn't it
wasn't disrespectful yeah he wasn't he
wasn't disrespecting you but at that
time i just don't think not about this
thing wasn't as big of a big deal like i
just think it was just like it wasn't at
all but it was just like how how this
[ __ ] appeared you know what i mean
that's why it wasn't a big deal that's
why i just do a one line in here i'm
just representing my i'm i'm standing up
for my city i didn't know for sure from
my city no
it wasn't a big it wasn't a big it
wasn't personal um that other [ __ ] was
personal i i i i see that i should
personally at that time was personal i
don't really give a [ __ ] now um all
right moving forward man
without getting too much into this i
want to get to the line though because
you're saying
i want to i want you to get to that line
man which one you say in the capital
steve [ __ ] and i want to
i mean i have people in my life who've
committed suicide yeah we all have
people in our life they couldn't
was maybe in poor taste
with that being said but remove remove
the personal from it that's what people
can do everybody wants to laugh at the
ugly baby until they have a baby that's
ugly what is it not funny he was just
laughing at the ugly baby
you said that baby was [ __ ] ugly now
you have kids you don't want to say no
more let's remove the personal [ __ ] and
just dealing faster but i think that's
why i think that's why
it's hard for people to remove personal
feelings from something that's
so serious it shouldn't hurt for me
because i'm i'm i'm solid i'm one honey
with myself always and you reacted and
like you said you that's how you chose
to remember
you ain't gonna see people more more
solid than me that's [ __ ] rare
because i don't meet them i know how to
i know how to be objective and like
remove personal [ __ ] from what's right
and what's wrong you feel me i know how
to do that like
it's just a [ __ ]
you you have to do you can't call
yourself real
you can't call yourself real if you
hating on people you can't call yourself
real if you let your personal feelings
get in the way of what's right and
what's [ __ ] wrong like because you
wouldn't be saying that if you didn't
have a personal experience about it
my [ __ ] you can't say yo i believe in
god and i believe in the bible and then
turn around and say you're wrong for
saying this like am i wrong if i if the
guy in uh minneapolis who i jane really
was [ __ ] with right through you
if he stops playing my record cool other
people call me um even even sway in the
morning was like all right man i was you
right but that was [ __ ] up whatever
cool
so all these people stop
uh supporting my [ __ ] publicly right
even though they know that you know some
[ __ ] i said was right
if i got to go through all that and
[ __ ] never play my record again
you know why it's worth it
because i've had multiple people
multiple people i don't be here lying
call me and say yo not call me on
personal phone like dm me contact me and
say yo troy
i'm not gonna friend
i was going through it i was thinking
about doing something stupid right
killing myself but
what you said
made me uh rethink it
and because you didn't glorify
suicide
who wouldn't kill yourself if they say
yo you're going to be with 40 virgins yo
you're going to be amazing if you do
that long live you
if they know that that's the reaction to
killing themselves why the [ __ ] wouldn't
they do it
[ __ ] i might consider it but if i know
the reaction is you [ __ ] idiot you're
selfish you left your family you're a
[ __ ] life is the most precious thing
that you can have why would you do that
you dummy
it's gonna make you think differently so
that's what i do i say yo don't be a
[ __ ] junkie i don't say oh it's okay
you're using drugs everybody go to think
no don't be a [ __ ] junkie you're
gonna think it'd be a bum
so that's gonna make you be like oh yeah
i'm not getting no pity from
[ __ ] and that's how i come from
and if i gotta go through all this [ __ ]
to stop
three four five people from committing
suicide and killing himself
that might be my purpose
that might be my [ __ ] purpose god
might put me here to be that angel and i
gotta go to hell so [ __ ] could
get to get to heaven so my next question
is when is you and logic putting out the
suicide prevention hotline sequel slash
remix wow logic dissonant
you don't know the song but no he put
out a record i really don't be listening
to people rap you see what the [ __ ]
type of [ __ ] i'm talking about
what what he did what did you do he just
put our suicide prevention song that
there's nothing wrong with that that's
good that's a good thing that's what we
need more of not long live you when you
commit suicide let me ask you this bro
like you went through a couple of
attempts on your life
uh the last one was what was on
christmas or christmas eve yep um
and we've seen so many people
die recently you know what i'm saying
like we've lost a lot of a lot of people
in the last since that since you
you know since that your situation a lot
of people have passed um
how did like like how did that change
your life and make you
like that did it change your life like
did you have to re-evaluate certain
things certain ways you move like being
moving you know like how did that change
i think everything for you only
only like the the music [ __ ] like the
whole irving plaza [ __ ] that made me
re-evaluate [ __ ] but like
oh i've been
i've been having attempts on my life
before that right i just wasn't
glorified because i wasn't an artist or
a musician so like i'm no stranger to
this street [ __ ] i'm no stranger to
being
i've been shot before i don't i was
never glorifying i should have talked
about it in my in my raps i was in
shootouts when i was 15 and i got shot
you know i'm saying like that [ __ ]
happens when you coming out the streets
so i was always trying to get out the
streets and um
the only thing that made me move
different like you know you always ice
up and be more on point but that's why
[Music]
it's like hard to say [ __ ] without you
know what i mean when you're on camera
you don't want to talk about
but um
the music [ __ ] when when that [ __ ]
happened when i'm actually playing the
business losing banging who's you know
all right and that was the homie that
yeah that's exactly you know how good it
means some good times you feel me that's
the fight yeah i remember um
but
like when you trying to do the right
thing and you at work you at your place
of business mm-hmm it's like how um i
think dracula the rule of homeboy was
like yo he was draco worked right jacob
jacob he was a problem he was there he
was he was there to perform
he went to work what i'm trying to say
if you're going and you're doing street
[ __ ] like even christmas
i mean the street environment is what i
i could accept that you're moving around
in the head you know what i mean foreign
and you know [ __ ] undesirable grimy
neighborhoods whatever that [ __ ] come
with that but yeah when i'm going to
work you don't expect that when i'm
going a place of business trying to
better my life you don't expect that you
feel me so that made me really move
different and see [ __ ] totally different
so like like i said i've been going
through street [ __ ] way before that i
don't talk about because i'm not when
these dumb people that incriminate
themselves and all kind of [ __ ] but that
ain't that don't even scratch the
surface so
and the reason why i'm here is
god i'm blessed right and my reaction is
different i'm not
people watch so many movies you see a
lot of [ __ ] get shot me falling
on the floor watching [ __ ] movies
when you get shot or they shoot somebody
whatever you don't have to lay down and
die dog you can fight for your life even
if you go even if you're taking your
last breaths you make a choice to lay
down and die you feel me or are you
paralyzed are you head tapped with you
every day whatever no you still even if
you get shot in your [ __ ] heart you
still have some adrenaline left right
and
and that's what i chose is fight or
flight and i'm gonna fight every time
i'm gonna get home in my kids i'ma keep
getting to this money you feel me this
is not gonna stop i'm gonna keep
dropping music i'm gonna keep spreading
the word the gospel like i'm gonna keep
being blessed and that's the type of man
i am and
all of that speaks to my character from
everything i said i i never have no hate
towards anybody i never diss nobody for
no uh reason no that's what suckers do
suckers pick uh sucker start problems
real ones finish it you feel me i'm
never gonna go out and just take a jab
at you because you're doing something so
what i'm saying i'm the number one
independent show me facts that prove
different and so even if i want to say
it so what
yeah even and that's
and that's why i'm here and i always
flourish so even after me going through
everything and going through courts and
losing people and having to get rid of a
whole entourage how i still level up
i'll come out and have
25 times more than what i had at that
time you post a full and there'd be
nothing left you're supposed to be done
bro i'm just i'm literally sitting here
talking about i lost over 150 000 and
just i ain't losing not gonna wait i
think we gonna find it in the airport
right there i ain't run out of here like
go find my [ __ ] i know i got my health
[ __ ] it i'll get it back yeah you know
what i'm saying so that speaks to my
character and that's why i'm different
and i'm i'm just not letting [ __ ] [ __ ]
don't bother me no most whatever
everything i'ma say and do i stand on
the bible and on god and if you got a
problem with me take it up with god i
bet you won't would you do a sequel to
new york city album because that's my
favorite project yeah absolutely but
it's gonna be it's gonna be telling the
right way like i'm about to drop bricks
in my backpack for mm-hmm that's one of
the best experiences pictures
one of the best series ever sure you
know what i'm saying i'm doing part four
i got the artwork and everything but i
don't just do [ __ ] you're not gonna hit
nobody on new york city the album that
don't fit right that you you would you
would never hear that you know what i'm
saying so if i'm doing a record like i
don't know i'm not gonna say it but
whatever
but i just want to be clear it's
different types of music and there's
nothing wrong with putting people in
groups and when we start jumbling and
[ __ ] that's where you get
people who can um
say well you shouldn't like there's no
way in hell that
that anybody removing personal feelings
aside should be like
troy ave is wrong for doing this or
doing that
how
house wait how
how kev how how's he wrong even ask sway
you could act sway and be like how sway
well you know
you're right but you can't do that in
public
that's how i sway why can't i do that
[ __ ] in public why can't i why can't i
spread the word of god and stand on god
in public well you know
you would have got canceled in 2022 if
that [ __ ] would have came out
they can't [ __ ] cancel my i'm
uncanceled because i'm still getting
money my goal is not to be uh popular my
goal is to have
the the most popular money you know what
i'm saying i don't want to be the most
like i want to have the most biggest bag
um
i want to talk to you man have you have
you uh
have you and ho vane talked at all is
there any any um yeah
me opening straight
so you guys have uh
patched up the relationship
yeah i'll [ __ ] with the whole week
you guys like was like it was like that
whole dame energy man it was like that
you know and
and i'm real tight with hope still and
obviously that was kind of one of the
more disappointing things that had
transpired out of that situation was to
see
you know in my opinion the breakup of
bsb it kind of felt like well i mean
i mean you got to look at the facts
again you know what i'm saying like i'm
not i'm only on dealing facts if
somebody tell the truth there's nothing
wrong with that telling the truth
you got to ask yourself
why did that happen you gotta look at it
and see why why why did it happen
so you guys are cool now though how the
conference like how's that first
conversation go
because i'm sure
it has been a while we just kicking it
about some other business
that that you know we
we had some other [ __ ] we had to settle
so
it just went from there you know what
i'm saying it's just like we got history
history like big time yes so
you know i was just i was most so
disappointed in them that
in him that yo he didn't he didn't stand
with me how i would have stood with him
like no matter what i'm not letting
nothing if i hear shots go off and
you anywhere in the vicinity 20 blocks
i'm getting to you no matter what
you feel me i'm not like no matter what
i'm looking for you that's how that's
how i'm moving with my peoples because
i'm militant like that and i got real
love like that you know what i'm saying
so
that i was most at this point like damn
dog you do me like that after everything
you know what i'm saying and then
so and that's that should be the
question that everybody asks now you
know it was other people there that you
know
sometimes [ __ ] react different
in fight or flight i'm always fight
right but
this is all about being on man [ __ ]
there was other people there that they
took flight but they came back yo
yo bro i ain't gonna hold you man i i
was scared i was scared my [ __ ] i love
you yo you know i'm sorry but y'all yo
i've never been on [ __ ] and then you
know what i accepted i embraced it
sometimes you just gotta say you're
wrong and apologies could fix [ __ ] if
there's history there
you know what i'm saying but some things
you you owe more than that so yeah i
feel like you guys are like brothers man
yeah that's the fact that's a fact like
wherever i thought
is my god my god child and all that
so it was like real [ __ ] it's like you
gotta ask so say you out i don't know if
you got brothers but i know you i got a
sister all right yeah that's the fact
but let's say you got your wife if you
go out with your wife and you in the
supermarket and she said kelly can you
go over the i'll
give me some milk and whatever
and then you hear some shots go off and
[ __ ] i should run to her what would you
do no i'm not saying i'm just making
sure what would you do no i'm making
sure no matter what right yeah
exactly so when that person didn't do
that there's no excuses for that it's
like
come on because you we tight like that i
would do that for you
we tight like that like for real for
real you know what i'm saying so when
that happens it's just like
and you didn't realize that until you
had saw
that when i was in when i was in jail i
was because they they kept telling me
like it was right there right there i'm
like how you was right there
because it was only me trying to because
yeah because that was the the first it
was only me trying to pick up bingo's
body yeah this it's only it's mad videos
that you don't see right right it's me
and block we trying to pick up being a
body and well basically me black had to
do something else but
when you're telling me you right there
i'm sitting in jail in a wheelchair like
this you're like you know it was right
there like if if if
hitler just came clean over it and then
said it i'd have been you know what you
my [ __ ]
[ __ ] it guys let's let's move on from
here don't make it happen again or i
know how to move with you you know what
i'm saying but it's still love there but
it's like the lion part that made it bad
like yo i was dead no the [ __ ] you
wasn't there because if you was dead you
would have seen me struggling with my
man body while you dying trying to pick
them up
so don't tell me that
so those are the things that people
don't see they don't see all of that
they just see the
the the ending yo choi abs bugging and
he's cutting off people no i'm doing
[ __ ] for a reason i'm saying this about
kendrick lamar because he said this
about new york this came after i'm
saying this about joey bad because he
took shots at me and had his and brought
his man into it so i said let's let me
respond and bring some more your mans
into it you know what i'm saying i'm not
[ __ ] with um
the bsb people or some of them that was
there because they did this i feel like
he left me for dead they didn't react
and then it wasn't no
i was scared you know i apologize you
know what i mean like how would you do
y'all just some [ __ ] [ __ ] i can't in
front
had did hope has hovan like acknowledge
that at least to you no you guys talked
it was like what's understanding had to
be saved would you guys would you ever
work with him again
yeah i mean
yeah i would it's just like
as you as you grow and you just are
learning [ __ ] just be different man it's
like
a lot of times i had played in music i
put personal [ __ ] so like i put i put
whole ringing on like that was my man
from the hood and he's killing it right
now we still drugs together you know
he's doing he's like he's doing his
thing i put him on like yo here come on
here i'm gonna believe in you any
situation i had even like i said in
in in a record like when i had my first
uh
uh
management deal through butch lewis i
say yo butch i'm gonna come get with you
but
i need you to pay my peoples who've been
who've been um with me since day one
nobody's doing that right i got them
checks knowing that them checks come out
of my money you feel me i got both of
them checked him and k cash shout to k
cash just he was just at my own condo
the other day but i got them checks like
i always bring my people and put put
them on are you are you proud to see
like what obedience is doing right now
though because he's he's doing his thing
i'm gonna keep it above me i don't be
like i don't be like looking at [ __ ] at
all bro i don't i'm not a nosy [ __ ]
like only time i started following like
different [ __ ] like at one time i just
unfollowed everybody because i didn't
want to see [ __ ] right right i was just
like [ __ ] it i was upset i ain't give a
[ __ ] about no music [ __ ] you know what
i'm saying i don't want to see because
it was all fake to me all of a sudden
you feel me mm-hmm it was like the
person who just
and get rid of all the pictures in the
house i don't [ __ ] with them right
it should happen so and then i'm not
nosy where i'm going snooping around
right right if it ain't in your
peripheral you're not i got them i got
real life [ __ ] to do i got real
businesses i got real i got a real life
going on i'm really a full-time dad you
know what i'm saying and i'm really into
the bag and it shows so you can't get to
the bay if you're watching everyone
else's bag it's hard to eat if you're
looking at somebody else's plate you're
going to keep missing your mouth facts
so that's real [ __ ] like i don't know if
you tell me
like you saying like yo he killed cold
ass what's up
like
more power to him i'm i'm
whatever and i'd saw the vision like i
said i set all that off you know what i
mean so like
whatever
but
i don't i don't watch face like like
they would say in brooklyn something
you've been watching
that i feel like has
probably like
proven itself to be a hey maybe troy was
onto something is that the streets is a
myth
first of all this podcast is a miss myth
because why the [ __ ] you bought me a
7-eleven pure water i want you drinking
essential oil well not because you're
drinking essentially i've had this
i wouldn't do him like that i would not
do that i already had this
first of all look at the ph levels on
that water the ph levels
like that no there's no that that's not
is this alkaline would it yeah i don't
give a [ __ ]
we drink tap water with lemonade listen
bro this is from my city
when i'm going to 7-eleven i'm buying
those okay that's why i got myself
another
i got to get my gallon in i'm just
[ __ ] with you this guy so yeah nah
but the streets is a miss [ __ ] like i do
feel like we've been note like like man
this this rap [ __ ] and like
just kind of like the perception of like
you know we were talking about the
jacksonville [ __ ] earlier where it's
like there's so many people just ending
up in jail bro like for just trying to
i don't know
keep keep up their perception or keep it
quote unquote
i think that that part
doing [ __ ] and going to jail that part
is not a myth
the myth is what's supposed to happen
all the rules after that was supposed to
happen so if somebody killed if somebody
if somebody goes to jail you post it
you're supposed to take care of their
family they're kids
they're lawyers
they're with you they hold me down
you're supposed to do that you're never
supposed to try to [ __ ] your homeboys
girls
ever you know what i'm saying if
somebody killed your homies
you supposed to go and [ __ ] ride and
be killing them right that's why you see
me on on
my case is the get back
[ __ ] shot
me killed my best friend and you see me
going to get to get back right there
mm-hmm that's what it is it's something
it's self-defense like [ __ ] you
still
you don't see that from people you hey
you see [ __ ] dying and then
that just be it whether it be people in
the streets or whether it be artists
friends that die or whatever
like
in the hood you see people that die and
then time will pass and they'll be like
getting money with the people who have
something to do with the death
i'm not getting money with a friend of
yours a cousin or family member is it's
all open season or whoever's associated
with that
if they if if
if you if you kill somebody that
i love is whoever you love
that's a fact until you going so like
you see that all the time that's why i'm
talking about the real [ __ ] everybody
want to pet the line until he show his
teeth right so like
you see it time and time again how many
rappers gotta die and then people that
killed them is still living and laughing
and going on about their business how
many times in the streets [ __ ]
gotta die and then the people that
killed them is still around the hood is
small
you 20 block radius you still out you're
going to the same parties oh nah it's
hot i'm not gonna crash out you can't be
in the club with somebody that killed
your homie yo i'm not gonna crash out
now but then you're loving that stronger
because in the hood it teaches you you
deal with everything on site don't
[ __ ] play or is that a myth
is that only is that is it only sound
good coming out of your your mouth they
only sound good coming out the mouth
with people who ain't gonna do it yeah
cause they actually ain't gonna do it
applying yourself to that code so that's
my fault for taking [ __ ] literal i'm
taking [ __ ] literally like yo and rap
it's no rules jay-z threw the [ __ ]
condom on on the back seat right you
know what i'm saying the locks was sorry
miss jackson like all type of
disrespectful [ __ ]
but then when i get in i do it whoa whoa
hold on that's too much
i come from if somebody try to take your
life
or they kill when you you go at them
immediately right whoa whoa troy ave is
reckless and dangerous he's shooting up
a cub and all kind of [ __ ] whoa okay so
this [ __ ] is a myth all this [ __ ] is
fake
but that's why the suckers begin to
elevate
you know what i mean but good thing by
the grace of god i'm still paid like i
was saying earlier i feel like you've
still been putting music out but i feel
like there's a new energy where i feel
like you're kind of like
back dug in
is that is that fair to say do you feel
like twenty twenty two like doug and i
like just like like i feel like you're
like back to like really applying
yourself to your music [ __ ] like not to
say you weren't like yeah you were
putting [ __ ] out but i was i felt like
the energy was different like it was
just kind of like you know we're just
gonna put some [ __ ] out and see what it
does and yeah it was just really i was
just running up streams are you like
back on are you like back in as a fact
i'm back in on it as
as much as i can be like i'm taking it
i take it more seriously the time that i
do it so like i'm not a person that
records
a hundred songs and then i pick the best
well i just feel like such a beautiful
album i always tell everybody like man
troy ave you know i was such i still am
a big fan but man i was one of your
biggest [ __ ] supporters and like i
always felt like
you you need to support my [ __ ] more and
play it when you on 923 man i know you
gotta you could you you almost ain't
tired man i know i'm not from the west
coast but in terms of just like um
i just i felt like
as a as an artist
i i just assumed you were gonna have a
million platinum records because like
you have a knack for writing
like [ __ ]
hooks bro and
you're like an amazing songwriter great
at melodies like
so
i'm planting them in the streets i feel
like after everything i feel like after
everything happened to irving plaza and
like you know the crew disbanded like it
just it just it just never felt that
like like i feel like the last couple of
years at least just felt like
yeah troy's still rapping but like is he
still like care about this [ __ ] type
[ __ ] you know what i'm saying my arms my
arms like being tired it ain't much i
could do like promoting and different
[ __ ] like that so out my heart wasn't in
it to make those out until now until so
now last year killer be killed that i
dropped um
goddess great paper straight [ __ ] like
that like those are like projects like
real those are like new york city the
album made you without a deal real
projects but before it was just like man
let me put this [ __ ] out run up streams
and that came from when i came home from
jail
i couldn't um go do no shows i couldn't
do now i was on house arrest right so
i'm like you know what
let me just drop [ __ ] just to get the
running streams and get the residual
coming in once you started doing that it
just became a habit you know what i'm
saying
and then so yeah so you were instead of
dropping music for the passion and being
like i want to put out a classic album i
was just dropping music just to add to
my catalogue
helped him up it was it was it was
records in here that was passionate and
[ __ ] like that right but i never gave
him my old because i got a whole lot of
other [ __ ] going on
now i know how to i don't know if the
word is compartmentalized where i could
yeah hey it's hard to like split up your
bandwidth when you're doing so much now
now
now i lock in i believe yo you know i'm
gonna focus on this album i'm i'm not
doing [ __ ] for two weeks but doing this
album right i'm gonna focus and knock it
out you know what i mean and that's what
i just got a schedule now where i'm like
like i really finally
less than a month ago
i always said i was gonna do it in my
head but now i wrote it down like yo
listen you're gonna drop four projects a
year
uh
you one is gonna be white christmas
that'll come out december january
that'll be number one
in in march four months later you'll
drop another project in june you're
dropping another project
[Music]
boom and then you drop three singles a
year and you go from there and you drop
in quality but like before i couldn't do
that before like guys are gonna tell you
i come with my album hey yo yo my
album's done yeah i want to put it out
in two weeks
you know what i'm saying like you know
i'm just no roll out just two weeks
[ __ ] roll out throw it out see what
happens i don't got time to roll out
just put it out the people who [ __ ]
people who are following me they're
gonna listen they're gonna stream it
they that's not the problem but you know
it's profitable that's fair but yeah i'm
back in
i'm back more like focusing with it man
i just feel good like
like i said man god is great and my
paper straight well on bricks on my
backpack four i would i would love to uh
hear someone from gazelle down there
that'd be nice that's oh yeah that's
fine i [ __ ] with um i'll [ __ ] with benny
the butcher i actually spoke to him like
damn [ __ ] other day i'm gonna i'm gonna
get him on something for breaks my
backpack on some coke rap [ __ ] that'd be
nice yeah well
rick's my bag oh yeah definitely coke
but even if you listen to all the music
my music is like no i know it's not i
know it's not but i'm saying that series
that's why i mentioned that particular
i'm gonna do every everything it's gonna
be like it's gonna make sense where it
fits it's not just gonna be for no
reason some people do it they gotta fit
right you gotta fail everything gotta
fit well there are people alone hey so
go go stream you gotta you got the music
streaming
cameras whatever go stream um
god is great paper straight and killer
be killed four projects coming in that's
the fact god is great pick me straight
killer be killed
i'm impeccable matter of fact don't
stream it [ __ ] that go buy it buy it or
not the itunes buy is spanx
on the website for the merch um
goddessgraypaperstraight.com but you can
go to troyav.com boom it's just one go
get everything um the 2022 season
project it'll be out by the time you'll
see this that's coming this month yeah
that's coming in [ __ ] january 21st oh
[ __ ] so that's like next week yeah yeah
it's coming immediately post boom there
it is pause super paws all right troy i
appreciate you pulling up thank you
perfect